yeah hi hi hi Jessica my sling so as
florida has introduced my dear
co-presenter is gonna be bailiff for
today and you should you could see them
holding yesterday's beer which they
enjoyed very much so we're gonna be
talking about 2560 bites is out to be a
enough for i mean if you don't get that
if you don't get this reference you
probably are pretty old or you just
watch a lot of memes on the internet so
my name is foggy which is the short for
each transposon skier from hungary or at
least is still rent an apartment there i
work basically doing devrel and a bunch
of other new technologies i'm a missile
attack speaker i've worked with the
missile devrel team doing the same thing
and i'm doing a bunch of JavaScript or
microcontroller stuff and hardware in
general so i'm a member of the castle
project which is basically what brought
me into hardware in the first place like
you're free years ago when this thing
went on one of the the crowdfunding
campaigns i ordered one and i started
playing around with that and did my
first presentation in budapest is a and
i JavaScript or microcontrollers and you
know basically he convincing people that
you know running JavaScript on a
microcontroller might actually be a good
idea or at least not being a terrible
idea
so why would that be I'm not sure this
talk is gonna sell it to you but
actually one of the creators john mckay
is giving you talk has given a talk last
year rebels talking about the whole
journey of the tehsil team there's a
reading list you should read up on this
it's it's fascinating how they use
javascript and not really use javascript
or a microcontroller and there are other
devices like yes pro you know that you
see on this screen this is like the
thing that you see is an USB connector
so this is literally a ton by size and
you can program this with javascript it
had a very strange javascript compiler
like javascript engine running on it and
something didn't think that was a that
was okay so they set out you to bring
javascript properly on
my controllers to be honest like yes
purino has has improved a lot since so
aspirin has also very capable chipped
and by now but but Samsung came up with
and eventually open sources Jerry script
which is you know it powers a lot of
devices you can program for example BBC
micro bits on it so it's a pretty pretty
interesting stuff happening and I forgot
to set this up so let me just set
hopefully yeah yep
no not yet okay that's not good not
working technical difficulties I guess
alright we'll see if we can get this to
work now you're talking
alrighty so let's talk about a bunch of
more interesting stuff like JavaScript
overt IOT just two years ago here and on
this very stage maybe in this exact
stage Babel announced that they are
actually running JavaScript on their
pebble watches and they actually didn't
stop until they could get script running
as fast and there's battery efficient as
they could run Java C code on the
microcontroller so you can see she
wanted fertilized of codes versus 39
lines of JavaScript app over indeed the
UI of a SmartWatch and when they want
defunct last year they actually bought
got bought out by Fitbit and my watch is
actually running JavaScript on the UI so
you can actually create apps and stuff
for your watch on a JavaScript but we
need to get smaller like these are
pretty capable motive chips so how about
putting JavaScript and D or
microcontroller like this have you ever
played with Arduinos before this is a
8-bit processor this is an order you
know micro it literally has two thousand
and five hundred sixty bytes of memory
it has it holds 30k of Flash
and you can do stuff like put space
invaders on it how well there are a
bunch of ways usually you use the
Arduino IDE and some C or C++ to code
that I created a small project that that
you can do this with JavaScript it
actually turns your JavaScript into C++
it's a good thing and he just mentioned
flow it actually uses flow in the
backend to infer your types and stuff I
don't have time to explain it but if you
want to just come up to me and try it
yourself and because that's all the
games that you're gonna be making or
they're going to be just JavaScript you
can just put them onto the web and play
them and after you play them you can
compile them and put them on T devices
like this one so this is a JavaScript
game running on a microcontroller
compiled for a microcontroller hardware
that has a 8 bit 16 megahertz processor
and you know if that's not enough you
know you can use this one which is
literally a tiny arcade that's the name
it's a tiny arcade box that you could
play with why would you why is that
interesting because this is just the web
this is just JavaScript and chemistry of
writing and you can check that because I
have some links up if you go to this on
with your computer or your laptop
actually you can play the exact same
game that is get that gets compiled down
to the microcontroller and the gaming
devices we have space invaders if you're
into that kind of stuff and we also have
a workshop so if your Icelandic or if
you're gonna be driving around the
island for next week just drop by
Reykjavik University next Saturday and
we're actually gonna do a whole workshop
we are creators of these devices
actually were kind enough to provide us
with a bunch of devices so you can't
actually play with JavaScript kid games
and put them onto a microcontroller and
play around with those and next Saturday
there is a link in there as well
and if you want to talk to you about
these kind of stuff at me at Twitter at
SL softworks or follow at cloud boy for
the new stuff all of this is open source
most of this is built on nodejs and
javascript so the whole server and hold
is all based in JavaScript so you can
contribute if you if you want you and
all the slides are online at Todd does
like that is yes that's a nice landing
domain right / place let's chase convice
land so thank you very much
there's a reading list and links if you
want to know more about these topics
[Applause]